こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは卵かけご飯が好きですか
僕は姉
スッキハいた元にゴハンゴハン2ヶ月の鶏の卵をかけそれはまずな子さんの料理のこと
でございます女寿命と白醤油が使われますねまあそうたいろんなアレンジがあるのです
がまぁ簡単にお薬せればご飯の処理をぶっかけで作る料理のことでございますパー金で
もよく作られますみんなを使ったことあるよねそうだろ町7丁っていうちょっといい絵
や田岡行くご飯いろんな言い方がいいます
卵ぶっかけご飯玉子ごはんたまごかっけ卵かけ卵べした罰るぼっかけ校
tkg とも呼ばれていますねまぁ今回玉岡ご飯に幹線で動画でございますっていう
けどそもそも卵9位右腕の歴史についてまずはおっしゃいましょう
相続等による日本人が食べる動物性の食品は仏教として別の途中で業界で行く通信だっ
たらでき骨や鶏肉のリングを食べてるぞ
あれにあったのです仏教の教えのルールなど魚介類を中心だったら
朝礼やだ魂は昔はな人間が食べるものとみなされなかったんだペンギンが食したから罪
に当たると考えられていたそうですそして江戸時代ベッドとして飼われるようになった
リバティのうがタバコがそれか無粋なんだったら羽化しないか生物ではないという式に
なりそれから束おかげご飯のスタートだったわけでございますそれで今回ですねタバコ
クッキーコーナー皆さん作ったことあると思うんですけどもそうそうもないどうして
あれだの講話
って変わってご覧に落とすべく6やって入ってきたみたいな感じでしょう甘いんで
あまり1位で今回です誰でも簡単に作れるスーパー頼ん彼ごはん2章エアリータバコ句
気呼果てのオセロぞもう
テレビとがネットで見たんですけどねってわけで簡単にやりたをかけごはんの説明を
しよう
そうそのたまごな普通はな張ってなご案内な影で流せてなちょいをかけるこれで判定
っていうのはまあ一般的なことでございますしかしなんとレジャー完璧においしいた方
がいいご飯にはならないんですよあないんでどうぞも何か食べたいっていうのを教えて
いきましょう
男っていうのは黄身と白身に分かれてるんだねーなーその後
卵をパカってちゃうと黄身と白身の割合が適当にこうランダムになっちゃうて均等の
噴火業務はできないわけですなのでそれを解決という排泄するための最強のたのーかけ
ご飯今日は教えようと思うよ椅子ようなこちらでそういうは後ハンガー
たマーってきまずオーナーの準備したんこしひかり動か豪華でございます2ねからこそ
回っちゃうんですけど待った後最初に公俊
のみを分けますうふふっ失敗した
展望地チャップあっ
うーんなんとか君だけはのボスってごめんねつだけとってください ok
こういう感じで君だけ完全に撮っちゃいました先に白い棒だけもご飯にかけちゃいます
でこの状態でもかき混ぜちゃいます
言いたいこんな感じでございますなぜこのようになるかというとですねこんな色見て
ドロッとしてるんですけどぞろっとなっている原因がたんばく質でございますいつも
ぞっとした感じであるタンパク質がごはんの熱によってかたまに末たぶんあれですね
あのあれです君を取り除くことによって責任白身だけはご飯と混ぜることによって本来
.千夏のたんぱく質がすべて均等に反応することによってフワッとした食感とご飯に
なりますまずおりま
したこんな感じでございますあとはさんたんでございますあとは先ほど取っておいて君
をご飯にかけて所有かけて完成でございます
えっ
おおこれは絶対おいしい西調布悪い卵かけご飯の完成でございます
うわぁこれやばい超混ざりやすいなんだなんかめっちゃ均等に戻るんですよなんか色が
ネオンな感性になりました
ではいただこうと思います
[音楽]
ああああああ
ジャスコこの動画が良ければグッドボタンつまらないと思ったらグッドボタンよろしく
お願いします girls next
[音楽]
しています